in our summer series American wonders we
are exploring pates places that make
America wonderful from majestic natural
landscapes to spectacular man-made
creations Sequoia National Park in
California is home to some of the
largest and oldest living things on our
planet and as Jonathan Vigliotti shows
us a visit to this forest is a step back
in time even in an age of global
connectivity it's morning here in
Sequoia National Park an ancient forest
high in the Sierra Mountains of
California as we made the climb through
its winding switchback roads this is
unbelievable the perps main attraction
reveals itself I'm surprised there were
accidents just like groves of some of
the largest living things on earth giant
sequoia trees stretching hundreds of
feet into the sky
giant sequoias have been described as
being living relics of an ancient forest
and just by looking at them you almost
feel like you're here around something
that's pretty historic Daniel
Blankenship is two Quay national parks
interpretive Ranger he's one of many
caretakers of this forest which is home
to its most famous resident General
Sherman the planets largest tree it's
not the world's tallest it's not the
world's widest tree either it's the
world's largest by volume one hundred
and three feet in circumference at the
base thirty-six and a half feet in
diameter it stands over 275 feet tall
but it's not just Sherman size that's
turning heads it stands nearly as tall
as the Statue of Liberty
General Sherman is estimated to be 2,200
its species is believed to date back to
the Triassic period when dinosaurs first
walked the earth more than 180 million
years ago when settlers first arrived
here in the 1800s and found these giants
they tried to tell others about their
discovery but the world didn't believe
them it's what's known as the California
hoax and all of these years later you
can understand why these towering trees
defy gravity the last few years have
been some of Sequoia national parks
busiest with travelers around the world
flooding through its gates for an
opportunity to get a glimpse of these
prehistoric Giants for now social media
posts will need to wait cellular service
here is nearly non-existent but that's
about to change
a new cell phone tower the first of its
kind has been approved for the park how
does that impact that experience people
trying to disconnect and journey into
the park not have to worry about the
addiction of answering cell phone
messages or what's the positive first is
safety in the park here we are at this
elevation in the Sierra Nevada mountains
hours away from the closest hospital
communication having multiple groups of
visitors being capable of communicating
and coordinating with each other so an
ancient forest gets a small modern
upgrade yeah an upgrade hundreds of
millions of years in the making for CBS
this morning
Jonathan Vigliotti Three Rivers
California
Thank You Jonathan Vigliotti if you
haven't been you must go you walk around
you you leave the day with a crook in
your neck how much time looking at it
really is spectacular they're majestic
and don't even bother taking pictures
take your pictures yeah you do it you
try to fit it in your little camera lens
you look at your phone it's like somehow
it doesn't translate pictures don't do
it justice unless you're shooting for
CBS because that look pretty good yeah
unless you're professional and speaking
of the professionals follow us on our
CBS Astoria Instagram page and also this
the National Park Service will be taking
over our account today and they will be
featuring photos from iconic parks all
across the country